Live from Jack Kent Coke Stadium stadium
it's the Battle of the Bin number one!
The undefeated Four Loko are looking to bring
their champagne tonight
but before they can get their tabs on the
Pimm's Cup,
they'll have to go through Joose, the new
QB from Mezcal Tech.
You know he's going to get blitzed tonight,
the rookie gets his shot to prove himself,
after their top shelf QB was suspended for
texting photos of his cocktail.
The skies are ever clear, the club seats are
filled and the cans are going wild.
Here's the kick off and it's a high ball.
We must protect children from the severe and
deadly consequences
of drinks like Four Loko and Joose and some
of the other ones.
And ever since this caffeine based, liquor
laced combo
has traveled the world from California's trendiest
bars to the Australian outback
simply because it offers a two in one combination
of things that late night revelers love:
caffeine and alcohol.
But making a superior Irish coffee is a craft-